how's it going everybody i am dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for today
april 19th 2021
as always click that subscribe button
right here on youtube and tap that
notification bell and maybe you'll see
our videos in your feed today we've got
three stories and i'm gonna get to them
quick first off just
all hell is breaking loose across the
country right now i mean it's just
it's just real and it is what it is but
we are seeing mass riots
and violence and i would say at this
point some level of domestic terrorism
by black lives matter and antifa and it
is being pushed
by progressive politicians who are
either slightly condoning it
full-on exacerbating it looking the
other way some combination of all of
those
particularly highlighted by maxine
waters who is a congresswoman here
in los angeles if i'm not mistaken she's
a congresswoman for like south central
l.a which is a pretty depressed
economic part of los angeles
but she lives in hancock park which is
sort of like living in beverly hills in
a
i think a five million dollar mansion so
she's doing okay after all this but she
had some crazy comments
while she was down in uh brooklyn center
minnesota this weekend so we're gonna
get to that
uh then there's just like a whole bunch
of new information about lockdowns how
and how ineffective they were and we're
going to break
yeah we're going to break into some of
the numbers so that you actually have a
little bit of information so that you
can talk to your blue and non-relatives
uh and finally uh anthony fauci
the faucist was all over the sunday
shows yesterday
all he is at this point is basically
just a pr machine who one week says one
thing one week says the other thing
the next week says some like half
version of both of those things
he was on all the sunday shows and he
really it's becoming obvious doesn't
really know what he's doing i mean
i just don't even know any other way to
discuss it so we're going to get to all
of that
and then i'm going to leave you today
with a little
little warmth a little takeaway that i
think you're going to enjoy
uh oh and i should tell you that i'm
actually in a particularly
good mood today because as of saturday i
have finished
my next book i have sent it to the
publisher
i've sent it to my editor so i haven't
finished finished like finish finish
finished
but i've finished the initial writing
part of it and now i get it to my editor
and it's kind of funny because i did not
expect to write a second book so quickly
and don't burn this book came out on
april 28th
of 2020 and somehow 51 weeks later i
managed to get another
manuscript in there and i think you're
really going to dig it we'll have an
announcement on the title and when it's
coming out and a whole bunch of other
stuff
hopefully in the next couple weeks all
right let's get to it but before we do
i want to talk to you guys about black
rifle coffee of which i'm drinking a
little bit right now
god that's good uh i'm super thrilled
guys to have black rifle coffee as one
of our newest sponsors on the show
black rifle coffee company is a
veteran-owned coffee company
serving pre premium coffees to people
who love america
yeah there still are a few veteran ceo
and founder evan hafer spent over seven
years on the ground overseas with u.s
special forces
and as a cia contractor evan even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of iraq to grind
coffee anywhere giving back to those who
serve as at the core of black rifle
coffee companies culture
in 2020 black rifle coffee donated more
than six million cups of coffee to
deployed soldiers law enforcement
officials and medical workers through
their signature buy a bag
give a bag initiatives this month this
month black rifle coffee is introducing
a new line of ready to drink canned
coffee
the new 15-ounce coffee comes with 300
milligrams of caffeine per can
a hundred percent colombian coffee high
quality ingredients and an energizing
blend of mct oil
and amino acids to fuel your energy and
focus for whatever mission lies ahead
whether you're big uh whether you're on
a big hunt or a cross-country road trip
ready to drink 300 gives you a
convenient way to enjoy premium coffee
when you don't have the time or
equipment to make your own brew
be among the first to try the new 300 in
two delicious flavors caramel
vanilla and rich mocha i've tried them
both and they'll give you some energy
people i promise you
order your coffee at
blackriflecoffee.comruben and use the
promo code ruben for 20
off your first purchase that's
blackriflecoffee.com
reuben make your mornings better with
black rifle coffee now back to me all
right
there's a lot to get to a lot to get to
so
look we all you've all seen the videos
and we're going to show you some of the
videos and i'm going to try not to as i
always do i'm going to try not to
bludgeon you with the endless violence
to make you scared but i think it's
important to know
that there's some seriously bad stuff
happening throughout the country
most of it's focused in minnesota right
now but of course it's always happening
in portland
it's happening in seattle it's happening
in dc it's happening in new york and
we're just sort of letting it happen
right we're just kind of letting it
happen remember uh january 6 remember
the insurrection of january 6 where
apparently nobody even had a gun
and now we're finding out that the law
enforcement actually let people into the
capital
well that sort of caused the second
impeachment of trump and it caused
uh you know all sorts we've got to look
at domestic terrorists we've got to
start spying people on
you know spying on people more and the
rest of it well now it's seemingly
happening
all over the country but it's happening
from
the left so you're not hearing out it
you're not hearing about it as much
as you might hear about it if it was
happening out of the right wouldn't you
say well anyway maxine waters who's a
congresswoman
here in california who i think has been
one of the biggest instigators
of the violence of the rhetoric of the
burn it all down
sort of sentiment that's going
throughout the country right now she was
out there with the protesters in
brooklyn center
yesterday and let's take a look and so
yes i would like to see the bill in
congress pass
on police reform but i know that the
right wing
the racist are opposed to it and i don't
know what's going to happen to it
but i know this we've got to stay in the
street
and we've got to we've got to demand
justice as a black man
despite all of the efforts i feel like
nothing changes
and george floyd is waking so many
people up yet nothing has happened just
but
you know despite the rhetoric like what
what needs to happen that's different
this year
and all the years we are looking for a
guilty verdict
we're looking for a guilty verdict and
we're looking to see if all of the talk
that took place and has been taking
place after they've struck
what happened to george floyd if nothing
does not happen
then we know that we've got to not only
stay in the street
but we've got to fight for justice but i
am very hopeful and i hope that we're
going to get
a verdict that is say guilty guilty
guilty
and if we don't we cannot go away and
not just manslaughter right i mean
oh no not manchester united no no no
this is this is guilty
for murder i don't know whether it's in
the first degree but as far as i'm
concerned is supposed to be congressman
what happens if we do not go
get what you just told what should the
people do what's your protesters on the
street
i didn't hear you what happens what
should protesters do
well we gotta stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active we've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
all right so there's a lot there i was
writing some of it down during during
the clip
okay so first off i want to be clear
about saying i said before i think i
said she lives in roughly 5 million
dollar mansion it's 4.5 million dollars
she's had a government job
for 40 years i i don't know how she
afforded that mansion in a district that
she doesn't
even live in uh but okay that's one
thing
so there's a bunch there that she says
now first off of course she blames the
right-wingers and the racists they
don't want justice to happen yes because
everything's about the right-wingers and
the racists we know that she says we're
looking for a guilty verdict
and as far as i'm concerned it's more
than first degree now that is what the
process
is doing right now there is a trial
right there is a presumption
of innocence there is guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt there is all of these
things that
the lady of justice who's blindfolded
that she is dealing with right now the
proverbial she
um just because maxine more as far as
i'm concerned
i want a guilty verdict well thank god
maxine you're not the judge jury and
executioner
now whatever happens here happens and we
can look at the system and say this is
wrong that is wrong
we have to you know deal with policing
differently more cameras
like the litany of things that we all
know we could maybe tweak or discuss or
all that
but she's basically saying if i an
elected representative of the united
states government do not get what i want
we will stay in the free streets forever
and also she said we will get more
confrontational
now that's basically saying right like
she's basically saying yes
we will get more violent we will burn
more things down we will throw more
molotov cocktails we will destroy more
businesses
we will threaten more people and stop
more cars and break more windows and
whatever else
that we want to do at what point
i've been bringing this up for the last
couple of weeks at what point
do the progressives are at what point
are they no
longer going by the oath that they swore
to protect the constitution right i mean
that's what they have to do if you're in
the house of representatives if you're
the president of the united states
if you're a senator that's what you do
you swear to protect the
the laws of this country
and she's saying actually if we don't
get a judicial
verdict that we like we will take to the
streets and in essence she's saying yeah
we'll burn it down
we will get more confrontational um this
is
seriously dangerous stuff and of course
the right
wing the right wing and the racist but
if you're new to maxine waters maybe
you're saying dave
dave you're taking maxine waters out of
context
there i doubt you can't show me other
video from a few months ago where she
was also
inciting violence against a group of
people that type of video can't exist
you see anybody from that cabinet in a
restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not
welcome anymore anywhere
you create a crowd you push back on them
you tell them they're not
welcome let's pretend this was one of
those
right-wing maniacs that the media is
always talking about
those scary right-wingers those evil
trumpers
imagine them saying that we're you know
we're going to scare those people
tell those people they're not welcome
the progressives are
everything they purport the rest of us
to be
scratch a progressive and find an
authoritarian that's exactly
what is going on here they are the ones
instigating violence please
please i welcome you guys to do this
i'll even go into the youtube comment
section myself
please show me where donald trump was
inciting violence
any more than what the two videos we
just showed you
of maxine waters including on january
6th
okay when he told people to do it
peacefully and again now we're finding
out that the police were told to stand
down
and basically let people into the
capital please give me one
instance where donald trump or any
republican politician
called in any way for something that
could be construed as violence in any
more of a way than what you just saw
that woman do
okay what she did literally this weekend
and what she did months ago get in their
face
they will not have peace you know what
was the other line
more confrontation more confrontation
okay
please show it to me and and at what
point are these people
are the are they culpable for the
violence that they're putting on the
streets but don't worry guys
i saw a video this morning tweeted out
by reverend al sharpton because when
there's a crisis there's nobody who can
pour gasoline on it like that guy
and he took a video posted it on his
twitter i mean the gall of this
freak he of walking onto his private
plane
to head to minnie to minnesota and it's
like oh boy i guess this thing has made
you a couple bucks buddy
like why would you want people to know
you're getting on a private plane
if you're there for social justice and
america is racist
and the green new deal and climate and
all of that but it's like john kerry you
know i mean he can fly all over the
world in his
airplane powered by ketchup or something
anyway it's all
just these people are just ridiculous
but anyway if you think i'm being sort
of hyperbolic or over the top about
what's happening in our cities right now
we put a little compilation for you
don't take today
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
i mean that literally looks like i am
legend this is happening in several
cities in the united states there
is basically a mob invasion right we
talk about an online mob a lot well
that's the online mob
these people coordinate online they go
in they burn buildings they attack
people they throw molotov cocktails and
the rest of it and where is
anyone standing up against it please
show me a democrat standing up against
it we've got a couple republicans
standing up against it not that it does
anything
but where is anyone saying anything
about this now imagine
just imagine for a moment if there were
trump supporters and people with
american flags wrapped around them
as opposed to just black outfits and
it's so great that everyone has to wear
a mask these days so you can never
figure out who anyone is
imagine if there were trump supporters
all over the country
doing this right what would the media be
saying what would joe biden be saying
well joe biden doesn't even know where
he is but he also thinks that antifa
is just an idea does that look like just
an idea to you and
let me just say one other thing about
this and then we'll move on which is
that
even if even if all
of the police killings any of the
incidences that these people purport to
care about
even if they were a hundred percent
right on all of them right
let's say there's no question without a
doubt that the killing of george floyd
was unjust let's say there was no
question without a doubt that the
the killing the other day of uh dante
wright
was let's say that one was completely
warranted um
you know completely unjust all of the
things that they say right
would burning down cities would be would
destroying federal property public
property
private property would all of this stuff
still be warranted
and if you think if the answer is yes if
you think well
even if everything that they're fighting
for if because everything they're
fighting for and right is right in
essence because of that
they can do whatever they want you are
saying to people that anyone who
believes they have a just cause can
basically do whatever they want
so they can destroy whatever they want
they can probably kill whoever they want
and this is just the beginning
if you think that your silence is going
to let this stuff go away if you think
somebody's going to come save you or
something like that
it ain't going to happen we're going to
play a video tomorrow but even right now
as we're speaking
just in the last hour or so ron desantis
in florida is signing laws
that are going to make a clear
distinction between protest and riot
because of course
you can protest but once you start
rioting and then of course what do they
also do they also defund the police so
now you have no ability to push back
on this stuff so it's just it's just a
whole bunch
of of bad stuff and are you gonna see
this
analyzed properly if you just watch
corporate media i suspect
that you won't all right guys two more
stories for you but before we get to it
i want to talk to you about hartford
gold
you know i spent a lot of time talking
about cancel culture and how the left
tries to silence people
and issues that they don't want to hear
about well here's something we cannot
cancel no matter how hard we close our
eyes or plug our ears
the biden administration is spending
excessively while killing energy jobs
and dragging out lockdowns we're still
locked down for two more months here
in california by the way this can be
catastrophic for the american dollar
which is why it's smart to invest in
things that are real with intrinsic
value
which is why i'm encouraging you to
invest in gold i recommend you speak
with my friends at american hertford
gold they say they sell
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door
or inside your ira plus they make it
easy
and with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients i know you'll come to
trust them too when you give them a call
today they'll give you up to
one thousand five hundred dollars worth
of free silver with your first order
so now's a great time to check them out
call 866-219-9311
that's 866-219-9311 or text
reuben r-u-b-i-n to 6-5-5-3-2
don't wait secure your financial future
with gold and now back to me
okay so let's talk about lockdowns
because it is about 90 degrees today in
l.a it's a warm
so-cal day and i don't want to get
myself in any trouble but i might have
had an illegal party here on friday
night with about 35 people and it might
have gone until about 4 a.m and believe
it you believe it or not nobody knocked
on us okay and this is all hypothetical
of course
but i did have some level of worry are
we going to get you know busted or
locked down or
you know taken out but nobody did
because i think people are just starting
to ignore
all this nonsense and we actually had a
neighbor here that threw a huge outdoor
wedding
yesterday and there was music blasting
and tons of people there and people have
just had it they've just
had it with all the endless nonsense uh
but
the the government in uh the united
states and especially canada
and in certain states in the united
states is getting worse they are they
are still
trying to push this craziness uh so
first we've got
from the new york post a little
something that's going on in oregon
right now
you're not going to believe this so
oregon is bucking the trend they're
floating an idea to require
masks and social distancing indefinitely
one of the state's top health officials
wants to require
masks and social distancing in all
businesses
indefinitely so what what in essence is
happening here that
in all of these states you know they say
okay we're gonna do it for two weeks
then then a month and then they have to
get like authorization again it's
different in every
state and it's also very unclear if they
even have the power to do any of this so
again right now
gavin newsom in california even though
he's telling us everyone can be
vaccinated
and we have five million vaccinations
already in and everything's great and
it's the spring and it's warm and all
that
he still has an arbitrary date june 15th
is the arbitrary date where things
can fully open up again and then still
people because of the
the mental damage that's been done to
people people are still going to be
wearing masks people are still going to
be afraid to go out and everything else
i think aven newsome should be in jail i
have no problem saying that the guy
has abused his authority there is no
science behind any of this and again i
think
i think over the next couple years we're
going to just see tons of lawsuits that
these people did things for political
purposes the reason he's choosing
january
june 15th is because he knows that's
when it's closer to the time
that the recall will actually be
triggered because they're looking at all
the
all the signatures right now and he
needs something to be like oh i've given
something to you people i'm letting you
open up but
it's all complete nonsense uh but if you
think oregon
pushing the idea that we're going to
just have lockdowns and social
distancing and masks forever if you
think that's bad
this is wild so this is cpac of ontario
canada
canada and there are legislature
legislators who are talking about
enhancing police powers
to enforce stricter lockdowns this is
just completely insane take a look
we have implemented the strictest
measures
in all of north america and the
difficult truth is
every public health measure we have left
comes with a massive cost to people
in their lives but we have never shied
away
from doing what's necessary we have made
the deliberate decision
to temporarily enhance police officers
authority for the duration of the
stay-at-home order
moving forward police will have the
authority to require
any individual who is not in a place of
resonance
to first provide their purpose for not
being at home
and provide their home address police
will also have the authority to stop a
vehicle
to inquire about an individual's reason
for leaving their residents
and our inspectors will also be ensuring
that those who absolutely must come to
work
are strictly following the public health
measures
for our employers and employees take
note
this is your last warning if someone
sees um
their neighbors uh breaking these these
new regulations
um and having a party in their yard that
sort of thing
should should people call police on
their neighbors in terms of
people calling um to snitch
to inform um look we all have a personal
responsibility
if it means saving lives then i think we
have to think about what your social
responsibilities are
as an individual to make sure that you
don't
empower other people and invite a whole
bunch of individuals to your home
let me talk directly to you guys you
ontario canada
legislators you guys are evil nazi
okay you understand what we just heard
there you should snitch on people at the
end
police now will be empowered to just
pull you over and ask whatever they want
if they see someone not at home
they can basically ask for your papers
and what you're doing out on the street
how do you think evil spreads this is
how evil spreads these
are bad brainwashed people and there is
a disease of the mind spreading across
the west and canada
boy are you guys jealous of our second
amendment now because
it would at least have more pushback if
that was coming in the united states but
i suspect
canadians who in many cases are are just
kind of nice and stay out of people's
lives
that they're folding quicker i think
they're just folding quicker
uh than say americans would not all
canadians there are plenty of canadians
fighting it you know that jordan
peterson guy up there
and my buddy gad sad and viva frey
there's a bunch of other people
ezra levant over at the rebel there's a
bunch of people fighting it
but those are horrific bone
chilling statements that those people
are saying
what they are going to do with law
enforcement and make sure you are
trapped in your house and again
i say this as the backdrop of even if
at this point we knew kovit was going to
kill 10
of the people on earth which we
obviously know isn't true and by the way
in texas uh it's completely bottoming
out right now and they've been open for
a month so
we'll get to fouchy in a second but we
know that
opening up is not causing any problems
okay but
even if it was going to kill 10 freaking
percent of the people on earth
at this point a year and a half later
this is all nonsense i would say you
have to open up anyway and actually in
retrospect and i just wrote about this
in my book
in retrospect i i don't think that there
should have been any measures taken that
would be my
personal feelings on this that you
should have been able to do what you
want and if you were concerned about it
you could have stayed home and if you
wanted to wear masks you could have worn
masks
and all of that other stuff but if you
think what is going on right now
that canada becoming a fascist state
which is exactly what's happening what
would you do in a fascist state what
would you do
you'd have police that are empowered to
do whatever they want you'd make people
hold their papers you'd keep people
locked up you'd keep them
nervous about fighting back from the
government you would keep people
snitching
on their neighbors that's all the stuff
that we just heard from those people
okay
it's coming it's coming and perhaps it's
here if you're watching from canada
and and if that's upsetting to you then
you you maybe have a little bit of a
window of time
that you can do something about it but
let's uh let's show you this chart this
is from statista
and they have proven which we've known
now
for quite some time that there is no
correlation
between lockdowns and per capita covered
deaths okay so take a look at the chart
right there
california and florida basically did the
same
exact thing despite the fact that
california has a significantly younger
population
florida has the second oldest population
michigan
did about the same as texas michigan
hugely locked down
california hugely locked down florida
not
texas not the worst performers new
jersey which is still somewhat locked
down new york which is still somewhat
locked down
and massachusetts and all of those are
probably related to nursing home deaths
so
yeah cuomo should be in jail too i mean
these people
need to be removed from office
at this point i really see no other way
around it
if you've killed an awful lot of people
if you've destroyed lives and destroyed
businesses as
as a public official you need to be
removed from office you know like you
need to be sued
and you need to be removed from office
it's as simple as that the stuff
doesn't work and again right now the
buffoon
elitist jackass gavin newsom who is in
charge of the state
still has us locked down for about seven
more weeks absolutely insane
but if you think that the insanity is
just coming from the governors it's not
because it's just sort of an
acquiescence of everybody so fauci
who's pretty much got everything wrong
the entire time
and who's now in many ways the biggest
anti-vaxxer there is because he keeps
telling people once they have the
vaccine they should keep
social distancing and wearing mess and
everything else well he he did the
sunday shows
he did the sunday shows because that's
what he is he's a pr
man in essence for vaccine companies at
this point
more than a public health official
although he is the highest paid person
in the us government that is absolutely
true
this is a video of fauci on cnn
talking about restrictions related to
vaccinated people
the obvious question is why are there
any restrictions they're all because in
a certain situation
one can get vaccinated have no clinical
disease at all but get infected and not
even know it
and have replication of virus in your
nasopharynx
and inadvertently transmit it to
somebody else who might actually be
unvaccinated
and get ill that's the reason why you
want to wear a man
fauci isn't he's an anti-matte an
anti-vaxxer
not an anti-massacre he's an anti-vaxxer
that's what he is
he basically just said in a certain
situation a vaccinated person could get
something and that could spread it to
someone else
then what's the point of being
vaccinated and even if that is true i'm
not even telling you that the specific
thing that he said there
isn't true okay but the point is if it
is true you still we still have to move
on with life we still have to move
on with life this guy is the griff that
never stops grifting he just keeps
wanting more and more power more and
more publicity
more and more appearances on these shows
it's absolutely ridiculous how are you
going to tell
the american public that everyone should
be vaccinated and then also tell us
that when you're vaccinated you should
still be distancing you should still be
wearing masks you should still not be
going out and joe biden's telling us
we can have small backyard parties with
our family on july 4th
maybe if we're good jesus christ fauci's
2019 salary by the way 417
thousand dollars that that's more than i
make is that more than you make
and uh he's done that with you know his
main goal of keeping people locked in
their houses and depressed
uh let's show you uh two more here so
now this is from msnbc
because he makes his way around you know
he gets on msnbc he gets on cnn neither
one of them will put me on that's all
right
uh and here he is talking about how
vaccinated people could still carry
the infection why does a vaccinated
person have to wear a mask
okay this is something that as we get
more information
it's going to be pulling back that you
won't have to but currently the reason
is
that when you get vaccinated you are
clearly diminishing
dramatically your risk of getting
infected that's one of the things we've
got to make sure
everybody understands you dramatically
diminish it
however what happens is that you might
get infected and get
absolutely no symptoms not know you're
infected
and then inadvertently go into a
situation with vulnerable people
and if you don't have a mask you might
inadvertently
infect them now there's a small risk of
that but it's there
the other thing is that there may be
variants that are circulating we know
new york area has their own variant of
526 there's a south african variant
fortunately for us chuck the 117 variant
that is dominant in europe and in uk
is also now dominant in the united
states thank goodness
the vaccine works very well against that
very
so what so what fauci even if some of
that
is true even if some of that is true we
have to move on at this point and you're
not even telling us
that that all is true and what in
essence he's saying is that if
this then there could be a small chance
there's a small chance that i could walk
out of my house and get hit by lightning
but i still walk out of my house every
now and again ah
he's just terrible oh and by the way i
think he's racist because he said the
south africa variant and when we called
this the china virus that was racist
so i guess he's racist against south
africans now too
just absolutely absolutely insane
but this is a beautiful moment this is a
beautiful moment so this is this morning
now
fauci was uh talking to talking to
congress
and uh representative steve scalise had
a made a pretty damn good point let's
take a look
dr fauci does this look like social
distancing to you that you require when
you talk about six feet
no so in these cells as you just said
they're violating the very guidance that
you tell americans to follow
a restaurant in the united states would
be shut down today
if they were being run like this yet the
federal government the biden
administration
is running this facility you can see
all of these young children who are next
to each other six inches apart
many without masks by the way does that
follow your guidance that you've issued
no well then why would the biden
administration not go
and stop this i think one of the reasons
is president biden and
vice president harris won't even go see
this for themselves that's why i keep
urging strongly that they go to the
border i'd love for you all to go to the
border
to see this so you can at least give
recommendations they're violating every
guidance
that americans are required to follow
that's a golf clap for representative
steve celise who was shot at actually
during the congressional softball game a
couple years ago by a bernie supporting
tolerant progressive lefty in case you
forgot that story that story went away
pretty quick quickly because it was a
lefty shoot one of those scary
right-wingers remember that um he makes
a great point like if at this point
we are to believe that any of this is
real if we are supposed to believe any
of it
then why are we keeping these kids in
cages why are they not socially
distanced
as he said some of them are not wearing
masks and fouchy to his credit
he actually in this case he admitted it
he's like no that's not cool
but biden hasn't been down there
cackling kamala hasn't been down there
and nothing is going to change but you
would think i mean you would think
we had to end the world in essence in
the last year right we ended
western society we paused everything we
destroyed lives
because of this uh pandemic now you
would think well if
then all of these people are coming in
and we're putting them in cages and
they're gonna spread it we're going to
send them throughout the country that
might be a problem
but notice nothing's going to happen
because of this nothing's going to
happen
and and fauci knows it and that's a
great job by scalise to endlessly call
out that hypocrisy
and i think that's what more and more
people have to do call out the hypocrisy
and then just start going on with your
life and that's why i was so happy uh
this past weekend because yes we
actually did have a party and we had
about 40 people
and we lasted for about eight hours and
it was indoors and it was outdoors and
we had tequila and we had pizza
and we had wine and we had cookies okay
um
and guess what i don't think anyone died
as far as maybe i'll get an email later
today a couple people
died but as far as i know nobody did as
i told you we had
we had a couple neighbors the neighbors
a few doors away had a huge wedding
people are just going to start ignoring
all of this and the other part is
that i think what's going to happen is
police are going to start ignoring this
they're going to start ignoring the
orders you know one of the things
that happened with the real nazis way
back when
is one of the excuses that the sort of
foot soldiers gave was i was just
following orders
and when everyone just says i'm just
following orders well then you get an
order from up top so let's say hitler
says something and then you've got
mangala and you've got
you know all of the other really bad
people that everyone knows their names
right you've got eichmann and everybody
else
but then the generals and all the way
down to the foot soldiers to the police
to everything else i was just following
orders
i didn't have anything to do with i was
just following orders but i think more
and more people are going to stop
following the orders and more and more
people
should i know for a fact i was actually
at a party
last weekend and police showed up and
the police basically were all saying
because i went out there
oh we don't want to have to do this we
don't want to have to do this and
i think enough is enough enough is
enough these people and
okay so now let me get you to the to the
positive part right because i always try
to end you with something positive
the positive part is more and more
people are waking up i assure you
and i was thinking about it this weekend
you know in this last year
for as crazy as this has been and for as
crazy as it's going to be and the next
coming week or 10 days or maybe more is
going to be even worse
because of what's going to happen
because of people like maxine waters
they
want violence and it is coming okay
but i want you to think about your life
for a second do you think a little more
seriously about your life did you do
some things in the last year whether
that was learning
to protect your family by getting a gun
or think about what school you're
sending your kids to or how you want to
live
meaning commute to work or not commute
to work or do you live in the right
house because you don't have an office
and you need to put more money into that
or are you married to the right person
or are you friends with your local
community or do you live close enough to
your family or all of those things
i think this last year and a half has
given us an extraordinary opportunity
to fix things and i know it and i know
it because i talk to you guys in the
reuben report community all the time
i know people are doing stuff i got a
gun this well i got more than one gun
this year i got guns this year
we started a garden several gardens this
year
we worked on a whole bunch of other
stuff a whole bunch of other stuff to
enrich our lives this year
and i think a lot of people have started
doing that a lot of people have started
to realize
the government is not the answer joe
biden ain't coming to save you
and if you live in canada you got a real
series of problems those are horrific
awful people
um that are that you know somehow rule
over you i suppose
um but the silver lining to all of this
is that in many ways what this feels
like is it feels like the system that's
collapsing so as we watch the
institutions that i always talk about
collapsing like who in their right mind
would be like you know i should be
saving 80 000 a year to send
my child to a college right now like
you'd have to be an idiot to do that so
now you can think about it differently
and maybe you could say you know instead
of sending my kid to some brainwashing
institute that bernie sanders wants to
be free
right even if they make it free and
forget the 80 grand well how about okay
i saved money up for my child to go to
college all these years he's 12 now
let's say
and you know when he's 17 instead of
that i'm going to say to him well here's
20 grand
to get going you know get a decent
apartment and get going
but you know what the rest of that money
that we save for you that's going to be
for a down payment on a house
like i think there's so many interesting
ways we can start thinking about the
future in new ways
on top of crypto and all of the
incredibly cool technological
stuff that is happening right now by the
way you know i've been teasing for quite
some time that we had a major
announcement related to locals and i've
sort of made the announcement
subtly on the locals community already
just for subscribers
but tomorrow we are going public with
some major news so tomorrow morning we
will make a major major
game-changing announcement related to
locals so there is
cool stuff happening out there i promise
you and just keep
finding the people who who want to live
in a world that you want to live in and
stop being afraid of these awful people
and and try and if you're a lawyer start
looking into how do we
start suing these people these people
should be gone from public life as
simple as that i don't believe in
violently attacking them
i don't believe in burning down maxine
waters 4.5 million
mansion but i do believe that these
people are now negligent they are
ignoring their oath of office and they
don't deserve our time they don't
deserve our attention
and they don't they certainly don't
deserve our respect so
the silver lining is there is good
things happening i just know it i know
if you're watching this show
that that you've done something in your
life in the last year to get it a little
more in order i just know it doesn't
mean everything's in order
right they also close gyms and people
started drinking more and eating or
doing takeout but like if you could just
start getting yourself in order
now now i'm sounding very jordan
peterson i guess but i think that's
where it starts
clean your room and then we'll see about
this world thing guys speaking of all of
that
part one of my interview with chef
andrew gruel who is just an
absolute freaking all-star this guy
uh from slap fish uh restaurant group
got a bunch of restaurants mostly in oc
and we're gonna do a live meet up at one
of them in the next couple weeks
um he has been one of the major fighters
against the lockdowns
he put his his public persona
and his business and his money and his
family on the line to fight all this
stuff
and he's just absolutely great check out
part one of our interview and he really
goes into
how crazy these lockdowns are and how
the government just screwed up
everything
one really interesting clip that i
posted on twitter this morning about
how when they had to lay off all these
people at the beginning and then when he
when he could start opening up and once
they were able to sort of figure out how
they could move forward
that basically all his employees were
like no we're not coming back to work
because we're getting 1200
a week from the government so why should
we work so it just goes into how screwed
up the government is how they're just
constantly putting a band-aid on
something that they screwed up in the
first place
the full interview of course is up
already ad free reubenreport.locals.com
and yeah it's going to be a busy day for
me i hope you have a good one as i said
major announcement tomorrow i believe at
8 am
pacific stay tuned stay strong
and don't stay right there i mean go
take a walk or something all right
goodbye